In the year 2039,
new developments in virtual reality
could give 'connecting with someone
you fancy' a whole new meaning.
Facebook already hosts a show
called Virtually Dating,
where couples strap on headsets
and virtually spend time
in exotic locations.
Imagine if you could go on a date
without the commitment of having
to actually be there in person.
A 21st Century romance?
Or just another way to
bash into the furniture
of your ridiculously
small housing pod
before you take off your headset
only to remember
there's no one there.
Alternatively, maybe your
VR date will go so well
you'll question why you need a real
life partner in the first place.
A company in Japan
is already offering men
the chance to marry
their favourite anime characters.
Will you be professing
your lifelong commitment
to a 3D hologram in a virtual chapel?
If you're a woman,
the answer may well be no.
Even though research shows
that people are more likely
to open up to a machine
than a person.
It also shows that women
are less likely to try
virtual reality than men.
A company's recent solution?
Turn the headsets pink.
It didn't solve the problem.
If by 2039 VR is more widespread,
could connecting to your partner,
emotionally or physically,
simply mean digging out
your VR toolkit
and plugging one of a number of,
ahem, devices into a USB port
or does the very thought of this
make you want to split up?
Or throw up?
If looking the one you love
in the eye is more your thing,
you might prefer glasses
that use face-analysing algorithms
to scientifically reveal
when someone finds you attractive.
A way to make dating
less time-consuming
or a virtual slap in the face
when you discover
that everyone you're pretty much
definitely sure fancies you, doesn't.
Digital technology is often
criticised for increasing loneliness
as people turn more to their screens
for support, rather than each other.
However, by 2039
we could be using dating apps
to connect with a multitude of people
in a variety of new,
non-romantic ways.
Will finding a partner
to settle down with
be something your parents used to do?
Either way, with nightclubs
across the UK closing down
and fewer young people
drinking alcohol,
it seems like the days of...
and having one too many of...
only to wake up with...
are probably numbered.
So if we're still going
on real dates with real people,
we'll probably need new venues.
For example, a trampoline park.
According to a recent report
there's been an overwhelming
rise in trampolining.
Imagine if this was where
you're meeting a hot
and very sweaty date in 2039.
New kinds of
immersive cinema experiences,
such as 4D or 5D,
might also pave the way
for virtual reality films,
which would make the cinema
the perfect place for a date in 2039
with friends, partners
or anyone in between,
just  like it's always been.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)